Hello everyone. It is meeting 13
of the active inference textbook group
cohort one. It is the final meeting of
this section. It's July 28,
2022 and we are going to be
especially thinking about feedback and
structuring on this textbook group,
on how the first half of the first
cohort went and
also the ways that over quite
literally the coming minutes and hours
and days we will be able to implement
structures to improve our
experience. For those of us who are
continuing on to part two cohort One,
as well as those who are joining for a
new cohort. In the onboarding
page there are two columns with
checkboxes and clicking these checkboxes
will sign you up to continue on in
chapter six through ten for cohort one
as well as or alternatively to join
in chapters one through five with cohort
two. So select one or both of these
boxes if you'd like to be continuing on.
That's the onboarding note. And again,
other than that, which I hope those who
are here or watching live update
according to how they want, other than
that we're going to be talking about
future Textbook groups and other things
like that. And then also just on the
informational briefly on the Future
Textbook Group page, here's the link to
share with people to join future
Textbook cohorts. So to join in and then
also please fill out this feedback form.
It's really important that even if
people think they have limited or non
valuable feedback, that they provide it
because whether it's on this page
directly where everyone can edit and so
every thought that somebody has like
even if right now they can just edit
this page or in this more anonymous and
asynchronous mode or through direct
communication but we're experiencing it.
And so we have the best insight at this
point into how to improve it and
the affordances that we're seeing today
or the state updates or however
you want to use ontology terms to
describe it. But what we're seeing today
we can do. So we should have a
fun discussion today on some of those
topics and then also look towards
project ideas, many of which are related
to the educational process and others
which are building on education into
research and application and so there
will be spaces for those as well. Let's
begin though on this Future Textbook
Groups page and anywhere
where people want to jump in writing
or speaking, how are we
going to summarize and
distill the experience of the last few
months in this textbook group and bring
it towards improvement in our coming
cohorts?
Yeah, I think having worked examples as
I've talked about and discussed with
Brock in Jupyter notebooks or even
simple like did you understand the
materials? Like question and answer,
like quizzes at the end of each chapter
or something like that, I think, which
just would be useful, like to gauge your
own understanding. Like if there is like
a definition or something that we can
directly refer back to in the text,
that'd be useful.
Examples. Yes.
Great. And the questions could also
include little tests of knowledge.
Not every question needs to be throwing
a baseball into the deep unknown. It can
be literally clarifying for someone who
believes that an answer is in the known
unknown space I believe there's an
answer for this, I just want to clarify
for my understanding. But also once
you've clarified that, and especially if
you did just clarify it, then write that
example because many of these are
opportunities for worked examples and
worked examples work in certain
situations. For formalisms, for example,
it might also work for formalisms that
aren't mathematical like here's the
system this way or this phenomena, how
do these ontology terms map?
Or if this is the blank, then what is
the other thing?
Okay, so we have anyone
else just go for it. Or let's just
continue to edit and organize and add
notes and just have more because many
people are having many thoughts on
directions to go and just like what is
the space of some improvements that we
can explore? And then how will we be
implementing some of these changes?
And then in cohort two, when someone's
like it could be this way and they've
thought of something that's new and not
on this list, we add it. If it's on this
list, we say awesome, we agree,
join us and do it's.
Anyone else with raised hands? Or we can
look more at a few other sections before
going to the projects.
Like when I see different regimes of
attention, I think one way that we
can structure that is by clarifying what
practices we're
explicating and where those practices
can take place.
So then, because the reality is and
people who are here or listening in
replay can give their input, many people
may not have known what exactly to
do to engage with the material.
There's a textbook, there's some regular
meetings, there's an information
resource and it's
like an infinite game to structure
beneficial engagement. And where the
rubber hits the road is like being clear
about what practices people can engage
in.
So if we have math,
everything has to be fractaled out into
sub sub subgroups, just including
many of the practices. Like if you want
to do art about active inference,
here's a practice and then if people are
engaging in that practice it does create
kind of like a group or a guild engaging
in that performance.
So however, people think like what are
useful minutes and seconds
that actually help learning active
inference and we'll be able to have a
perspective on that question in years
from now. That's very different based
upon better understandings of
competencies and the fundamentals and
the approachment to the area.
However, I think the practices table and
providing feedback and then sharing
and communicating how we're using
practices to increase understanding
could be very important for those who
are learning and learning how to learn.
Jessica and then anyone else?
Hi yes. I think to build up on sort
of like blue suggestion, I'm thinking
that in some of
the courses that I've taken, you have
the other participants giving feedback
as part of the learning process. You
give feedback on the other participants
work. So it could be that there's
an exercise and everybody has to fill it
up, et cetera. And then the
other participants, it could be like two
or three. So not everybody has to read
everything. Two, three people.
You read like Jessica's answer and give
a feedback and so on. Because in that
way, by having to critique or analyze
other people's work, it helps you think
through the material itself.
So that's another way of also learning.
Again, there's also missing.
You could be probably making a mistake,
also not applying it correctly, but it's
like a tool to help you think through
the material by analyzing somebody
else's work while also initially also
having to do on yourself and then
hearing also the feedback that other
people are going to be giving you. So
that was kind of like an idea that came
to mind, like making reference from
other experiences.
Thank you. Jessica yes.
I think that's a great area to
keep in mind and to balance
as our cohorts build and so
on, who's on the supply and who's on the
demand side of that, so to speak. Like,
who is actually offering the feedback
and then who is the people who are
wanting feedback. Like, some of these
projects are things where the
person was able to be brought
into another project like
Noah's and Mike's work, bringing them
into synchronous and asynchronous
resources that are already happening,
provided them with at least a first step
for continuing on their journey.
Others are they're
in different areas. And so how to keep
it open when people have ideas ranging
from educational improvements to
robotic deployments,
what kind of feedback they need, and
then how to balance the excitement
around applying active inference with
what it means to learn.
Like, there are biochemistry classes.
It's not all just biochemistry lab,
but who's to say that's even the best
way or anything like that? It's just we
want to make sure that we keep it
all in mind. Jessica yeah,
and I think this suggestion is not
connected to someone's project or Net 16
project. It's more like an exercise. So
there's like a short exercise that it's
going to be testing variational
inference or something like that. And
then every participant in
the class actually does the exercise.
And then it's assigned to other people
in the cohort to analyze
that person's submission. So it's like
three people in the course analyze
Jessica's submission and give feedback.
And it's going to be like for everybody
will be getting three
feedback on how they applied the terms,
or there are other ways that they could
be done, et cetera. If some of
the things are like math related I will
have to see because then the answer is
going to be more clear. It's not going
to be as objective but it's more
like there's a short exercise,
everybody does the exercise and then
some people then get to review that
answer of the person and give feedback
on that. So it's like separate from an
actual project.
Okay, makes sense. It's kind of like a
combination of having good example
questions with an organizational
structure and then like you said,
balancing like where there might be a
clearer measuring
stick like was this the right equation
or the right calculation or not? Versus
how did this usage of affordances in a
new context make sense to you?
And also
it's not just about getting feedback on
the person's idea. It's like the
practice of providing constructive,
ideally written comments is super
important. Like the secret side of the
questions is the discourse where
the kinds of things that questions and
ideas that send people on thought
excursions and research rabbit holes,
we can collaborate on that response
together and it doesn't have to be the
end all, be all.
But sometimes by putting like a seed
into the workspace, by putting like a
prompt or a question,
ten people could write for 5 minutes and
then there would be 50 minutes of
writing on that topic from different
perspectives.
Whereas if there's ten people also there
could be 5 minutes of discussion which
might add more seeds onto the table and
it might continue to invoke
whimsy or it might continue to
instruct if there was a broad
uncertainty that that 5 minutes of
discourse resolved.
Yeah,
I was going to say I think for the
questions it's like somebody has a
question that they're trying to
understand and everybody's giving the
crowdsource answer and helping sense
make the meaning of how
things are with the other exercise. I
think similar to I think what Blue wants
to do with the short exercises
to test whether people know the concept
or not. It's just like adding
by having people critique other people's
work and having to critically think
through the answer is another level of
learning because it's not just like oh,
I think this is the answer to this.
It's like, no, I really have to
understand one, the concept
that I'm using to evaluate an answer
and then also evaluate that person's
answer and kind of compare and contrast
and having to make that
exercise of critical thinking. I think
helps people learn in a
more in depth way because you have to
think through your own thinking process
and what things mean, what somebody else
was saying, et cetera.
And I've seen it apply to writing. I
mean, I guess it's maybe easier to
writing courses and things like that,
but yeah, it's like another way of
processing through the information.
And then also it
also maybe reduces the burden on maybe,
like, a person having to go through
everybody's answer and making sure I'm
the teacher, correcting everybody's
answers. You're sharing the
responsibility around everybody in the
group of
answering, evaluating people's responses
to an exercise.
Thank you, Brock. And then anyone else
with the right hand.
Just to agree with Jessica. And the last
part, I was going to add that, but yeah,
just systematically creating
a systematic affordance for people to
review or provide some
validation that it's correct or on the
right path or whatever will reduce
the burden there. And teaching
is probably the best way to learn it's.
Learning how to learn is like difficult
to do without teaching.
Like learning self learning is about
teaching yourself to get better at
teaching, you get better at teaching
yourself. Thanks.
Just the circle back. That does kind of
require some meta structure to create
examples or source them or whatever and
then provide them.
So I'm not sure outside of
the project that I put on there and
maybe it's kind of related to Yakubs as
well, but outside of those two things,
I'm not sure we have a clear affordance
to do that yet. For coming
up with examples of yeah. Like examples
to work or whatever? Yeah, either
sourcing them and then putting them in a
structure that says, oh, this is for
section chapter one or whatever 1.1 or
whatever. So not questions that are
related to specific parts of the
textbook with people to work through,
but what kind of. Table or structure
could be, I guess virtually the same.
But instead of a question somebody is
asking, it's an example for other
people to answer, maybe with an answer
that they can see, like if they want to
reveal it or whatever. Does that make
sense? Yes,
it could be an example to work through
in this course. It doesn't be in this
exact table, but just make sure that we
have written it down and everyone can be
contributing to write it down and what
the structure is because it's not like
this is an impossible affordance.
We can spin up the table right now and
template it and just start to design it.
And over the coming weeks we have time
to digest all these different inputs to
make it. So in a few weeks it
will fly by, but we might be able to be
implementing these things.
I wanted to ask, what practices did
people feel like they engaged in
fruitfully,
whether it's on here or not. Just when
you you felt like were participating in
the active textbook group, what did you
feel like you were doing and how did it
help? Equation translation? That was
like the most helpful thing that I did
and I don't think it's there. Well, I
guess it's kind of there. It was like to
copy the equations down, but putting
them into natural language was probably
like the thing that I did that was maybe
most useful for myself and others.
Yep, it was a great practice.
And it
it leads to and scaffolds
so many other why is it this way? What
does this mean? What are the examples?
It's not like the prerequisite per se.
It's possible to ask questions without
having the natural language description.
But whether it's a basic or a multiline
equation,
it helps bring consilience
to that discussion. Because there's a
non zero probability that then a term is
going to be used loosely or it's going
to be used one way. Then it's going to
be conversationally used slightly
differently, or people will not agree
on which ontology terms are invoked or
not, which can then have
every equation start to spiral off into
every possible ontology term,
and they very well might actually
connect that way. But being able to see
what is variational free energy, and if
there's some term that is being
connected to variational free energy
that's not being described in the
equation, that's fine. Like least
squared error isn't in the
linear regression y equals MX plus b.
So there can be formal and informal
concepts that are super important for
understanding that aren't with
a symbol. But this was a great
way to be clear what the symbols
actually are.
What other practices did people feel
like they benefited
from? What would they
recommend for a daily schedule for
somebody who wanted to learn a lot.
I think. Plus one there on
blues, like writing the equations,
which is like maybe a super simple but
open ended, almost kind of version of
Jessica's suggestion, but also in
general, just adding stuff to the
coda, asking questions.
Like if you read and you don't ask a
question, did you really
grapple with it at all? I don't know.
How do we improve thinking by writing?
And the actual number of typed words
that people add in as a proxy during
a discussion is one thing, but even just
afterwards, or on their own time frame,
how can we have ten
people who do read a chapter just
scaling numbers? Each of them could
think of several questions ranging
from simple I wasn't sure about to
simple again, like more like an example
one like what are the three kinds of
this? And it's totally known and their
answer is fully listed to research your
questions. But how could we have many
more inputs in terms of the
questions that people are asking? Do
people feel like they wrote questions in
their own notes but didn't
bring it into shared workspace? Or do
people feel like for themselves or
others that they observed that the
questions weren't actually phrased?
Jessica then anyone else?
I was going to share more about the
student practices. But I guess first of
all, the last question you mentioned
there were things that I didn't put in
the general textbook thing, which were
more about parsing information,
which was like helping me connect the
dots and synthesize information,
which Ali actually helped me a lot also
with some of that. But those things were
sort of like personal for me to try to
make sense of the material in terms of
the student practices.
Initially I was thinking to do every day
like an hour each for the reading and
maybe like an hour for the math to kind
of get foundational things.
But then I found it was better for me to
maybe dedicate, like, a longer period of
time on one day or two days for the
reading, as opposed to, like, a little
bit of the reading or chunk more. Two,
3 hours in one day and then maybe follow
up another day with a longer period of
reading as well. Instead of daily
reading. A little bit.
And I think that's more because I guess
for memory I mean, they do say to do
like repetition for memory but I think
for me it's like well read longer and
have the material fresh in your mind as
reading as opposed to going every day.
And then for the math, because I guess
there's less of keeping
the material press in your mind daily.
I was trying to do that. So then it fell
off a little bit on that part. But yeah,
at least it wasn't every day but four
days a week, at least like an hour or so
trying to focus on the math. But yeah,
that's kind of how my practice got
developed over time through the course.
So the textbook is for as
the research
people who want to apply in their
research, if we remember from the
introduction, provide readers with the
ability to understand and use active
inference in their own research.
We'll have a better sense after part two
with a more applied slide.
Who might the next cohort of the
textbook group be in
and communicate to?
Yes, over many iterations and,
you know, can go many ways, but when
people are thinking like in the next few
weeks who blue
wrote, okay,
can we review which questions and
understand because I
don't quite understand how.
If you want to check out the questions,
check out chapter two. And a lot of the
questions were so if you scroll down,
keep scrolling, keep scrolling. I'm
trying to think about which ones that
were skipped. Let's see. And also
there's no skipping there's what we can
address in the 1 hour or 2 hours,
right. So we can raise our attention to
all the important questions. Yeah, it
was just like and then I realized most
of my questions were of a largely
technical nature. So let me scroll
through the coda and see if I can find
them. But it was like in chapter two,
it was like let's see.
The general thing to me is how can we,
among other things, prevent question,
self censorship and filtering?
We know that question isn't just like
this one. Genius meets genius.
Perfectly framed specific answer that
will be understood in one sentence but
that question is like a broader space of
prompts that don't necessarily have
any prior on whether it has to do with
an application or it could be a
technical question.
Yeah, good. It was early. It was like in
chapter two and chapter three and there
were a lot of questions. I'm trying to
look at the specific. I'll have to look
at my own coda instead of watching you
beautiful people.
It just happened early in those
meetings. And it's not that there wasn't
time like that. We didn't address the
questions in order. It was like let's
skip this because it's technical, let's
skip this because it's technical. Let's
skip this because it's technical. So I
just stopped putting my questions in
because I feel like they're technical.
What does this little squiggly symbol
mean? And that's why for me the
translation of equations into natural
language was the most useful thing
because I feel like all of my questions
are technical, like related to the math.
So I stopped entering them into the coda
because they were just skipped over.
Okay, thanks. Well, yeah, I appreciate
it. Again, I personally
hope that we can have structures that
uncouple the perceived importance of
real time speech from the contributions
that people make so that we can be
really clear about which questions we're
going to be addressing in conversation
and use conversation for what it can
bring many things and
then have 200
questions in chapter two with
many upvoters or with whatever mechanism
that brings different questions to the
fore. So there
isn't even like the plausibility of
being skipped. It's just a question of
like what will we raise up and focus on
individually and as a group from the
many, many questions of different kinds
that support a
beginner with fundamentals and a
pre beginner with background and
somebody who's asking research questions
as well.
So I think one simple thing is
if you go back to the questions table
like you have an interest column
here.
Interesting. Yes, even better,
maybe there is what
we will address in the next coming live
stream or session kind of table that
is taken from the questions table.
But the questions table has no such
projection of what is interesting or
not, especially in some one dimensional
kind of like yes or no thing.
It's just a separation of random
things, prompts questions and then there
is some process to get it to what
will be addressed in the live stream
that again,
there's ways to try to do things like
randomization or trying to like ensure
that, you know, we don't continuously
ask focus from one person and
or things like that. The popularity
doesn't kind of win the day.
There's more complex ways to do this
that are kind of almost like decision
making processes like ephemeral
group processes and things like that.
But yeah, I think just
separating them it would be helpful.
There at least another
thing might be like zoom, you could do
breakout rooms. Maybe that's not the
format. But again, just that's
kind of an Ephemeral group processing.
Like perhaps everyone doesn't
want to focus on the same questions.
Should there be a temporary
split of verging of attention for some
short period of time and then recombine?
Don't know what that means for a live
stream or recording precisely but that's
possible solution.
Yeah, thanks. Gather is awesome for
these things but it does require clarity
around how it's going to be done. Like
mass one on one breakouts, mass smaller
breakouts and rearranging people using
their spatial location to express
different things and assemble into
different Ephemeral teams.
Okay, let's look at some project
ideas. Okay, so for
those who are here or not, I hope I'm
not misrepresenting anything.
Mike brought up some token economies
that's something that we've been
actively going towards in Active
Blockprints.
So I'll just add just a note column in
Active Block, for instance,
as well as as mentioned earlier,
working with Noah on some
more some related topics.
Okay. Audiobook recording of a textbook
just as we go through these projects.
I've recorded the first chapter and
the preface type materials.
Do people think that an audio recording
has utility?
And if so, is anyone interested to
pursue this avenue with blue and eye
because it's very defined and it
involves primarily the equations,
having natural descriptions and then
just reading and
it can go many other directions too.
But this is like kind
of a clear accessibility affordance for
different participants that might be
interesting as well as just get out
there on YouTube and other channels as
having that artifact
blue. I do think it's useful obviously,
if I've elected to I didn't realize I
signed up to be the participant lead but
I'm so happy to do it. Is.
But I do think it's useful as someone
who drives a considerable amount of time
every day. If it's not like I'm not
a very good auditory learner, but it
does help to reinforce the concepts.
And I just wanted to mention even if
you're not comfortable perhaps doing the
math or reading the textbook,
Daniel thinks he can read it until it's
perfect. I would prefer to do
some video or audio editing so that's
also an option is to do audio editing
occasionally. Daniel does it very
infrequently but I think there's the
occasional tripping over a word or
saying a word twice like when you lose
your place or something like that. So
video or audio editing, I do it with
Windows video editor. But audio editing
is also another possible affordance
there and it would involve reading along
with the textbook to make sure that it's
accurate that no sentences are skipped
and then to just splice out any mishaps.
Or just ask him to rerecord the Markov
blanket for precision just so you can
splice it over the trip up if needed.
Yeah, thanks. Definitely we would do a
multi part. I just did one pass on
the first chapter? No equations, et
cetera. Draft, but okay. Anyways, just
so people who are interested
here or rewatching can know about this.
Okay. Resources for conducting research
or developing active inference agents,
ways to facilitate the starting of that
work for participants. Just a seed idea.
A lot of this is going to be explored in
part two because
it's a recipe for designing the models,
and we'll have a lot of infrastructure
around that as well. So I
hope whoever wrote this continues in
that interest and builds
that starting point for conducting
research or developing agents based
around what they learn and see in part
two. Okay.
Okay. Also,
typing just directly in the code is a
little better than comments, because
sometimes it's hard to understand what
the comments are like referring to.
Okay. Complete mathematical overview of
active inference, derivations of key
results, maps of equations. Yes.
All awesome. Thank you, Jakub, for
suggesting this. I think
the closest related works are
in the active phontology and
in knowledge engineering and
other areas too,
and I hope that we're on this path.
So however Jacob or anyone else wants to
connect on that. Okay. Active
foundations. So here we added this page
if Brock or anyone else wants to add any
comments or describe how
some of these comments can be integrated
with textbook group.
Um, short answers. I'm not
entirely sure the precise way to
integrate it with the textbook group,
but there
are just perhaps this is related
to questions, making questions,
removing the stigma or whatever. Like,
it's just helpful, I think, to have some
affordance or regime of attention or
whatever thing that says,
hey, if you don't understand this thing
about active inference, that's a
foundational thing. Like, okay,
I get entropy and
I get energy, like the basic concepts of
them, but when you're subtracting them,
what the hell are we talking about?
And then maybe there's some follow
on questions about mathematically what
entropy is mathematically, what is
energy? Or what is Shannon entropy
specifically? What is the difference?
These sorts of things.
A, it's that an, affordance for that,
but B, it's also just acknowledging,
like, there's a wealth of knowledge
already here. It's not a
complete mystery what those background
foundational things are or what learners
might want to get out of some
relatively short course to get up to
speed and feel real confident reading
the textbook. And so there's
a kind of top down affordance
there too, I think, that needs to be
made for people that can say,
hey, there's a bunch of equations over
or examples over here that are these are
the most helpful ones I found for
understanding what Bayesian inference
really is, how that really works.
So I guess it would be those two
things. But if you look into the project
notes there on that project idea thing,
there's a little more detail
of just a couple of bullet points there
of just. It's really hard for people,
I think, to get into a new thing if
there's not a model. If you do chemistry
without Bohr's model, good luck. If you
have to jump, especially to something
like electron probability clouds or
something, it's just like why would you
do that when you have a perfectly good
periodic table and simple discrete
and it's enough even to do basic physics
like Newtonian stuff. Right.
You need a model. I think a lot of
people history is helpful. There very
minimal amount, but just this is where
this came from. This is why it's
relevant. It's really hard for people,
I think, to blindly calculate
without that sort of simple context.
So I just kind of made a
very rudimentary still kind of
scaffolding it,
coda it's already linked in that
project row, but I'll put it in that sub
page there too.
Super work in progress.
The idea is just these questions are
going to be asked over and over and over
again. There will be people coming from
a more mathematical, more physics, more
neuroscience from different backgrounds.
And so why pretend like that's
not happening or reinvent the wheel
every time somebody asks a question?
Like just having a central resource
where people can get a lot of value,
but also maybe ask a
question that's a little more they
might not want to ask and seem like it's
too simple or it's too whatever in
the live stream.
Okay, thank you.
Any other comments or thoughts on this?
Otherwise we'll just continue on for the
final minutes. Okay.
Textbook enrichment. Yes. I hope
everyone continues to annotate, figure
out also things on their own and explore
and like we're building something really
powerful with annotation. So I hope that
people can continue to be
enriching with the structures
that we're building. But yes,
so much of what this group has been
about has been about textbook enrichment
and improvement robot
modeling. Unless anyone has other
comments, I think learning from JF and
staying in part two will help.
And yeah, Jessica and then anyone else?
Sorry, I think I didn't raise my. Hand
from no worries.
Yes. Well, any general comments that
people want to provide on the textbook
group?
I think the live streams are super
important for the lab and the whole
space for maybe obvious reason.
The textbook group is equally important.
These are like the two most important
things that can add value to the space
and the lab participants.
Indeed, glad that those who have made it
this far see that.
And over
the right timescales in the right way,
we see more and more vistas
to increase the accessibility and rigor
of active inference. So I hope we can
hold that frame and focus
our attention to
provide these functionalities.
Because if it's statable, it's doable in
a way.
And if no one from the first
Cohort wants to be an active facilitator
or steward for textbook group two,
some of these changes will be
integrated. The more people who want
to step in to
steward in our participatory context
are going to be leverage points for so
many more people who come through.
So there's like multiple levels of
affordances for those who see them,
especially at the end of this section.
And it's been
quite a few months.
Any last comments?
Okay, I'm going stop the recording in 3
seconds unless somebody wants to say
something.